[Musique]
merci corineass nous accompagné pendant
cette première demi-heure vous êtes élu
de la s s membre du groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain et l'une des
chefs de fil du groupe socialiste sur le
projet de loi immigration on va
longuement parler dans quelques instants
mais d'abord cette marche cette
initiative annoncée hier par Gérard
larchéelle brune pivé les présidents des
deux chambres du Parlement qui appellent
à une grande marche civique contre
l'antisémitisme dimanche à Paris c'est
politique que le Parti socialiste appelé
de ses vœux dès dimanchees oui le Parti
socialiste à travers la voix d'Olivier
fort avait déjà appelé à ce que nous
marchions contre l'antisémitisme nous
l'avions déjà fait nous l'avions
organisé malheureusement parce que
l'antisémitisme est toujours là en
France et dès qu'il y a une opportunité
il explose dans des actes répétés
parfois violents et donc nous l'avions
déjà fait en début 2019 et et donc ça
nous paraissait normal de faire de
nouveau cet appel à un moment moment où
on voit bien la multiplication des actes
antisémites dans le pays et là c'est
bien que ce soit Gérard arché et yel
brun pivé qui se sont emparé de la
question que que ça ça suscite que ça
inspire des appels au niveau
institutionnel c'est une bonne chose oui
bien sûr appels qui ont été suivis par
la majorité par la droite évidemment
mais aussi par le rassemblement national
Marine Le Pen et Jordane Bardella ont
annoncé qu'il se rendrai à cette marche
est-ce que c'est un problème pour vous
oui c'est un problème le bureau national
du Parti socialiste on a débattu hier
soir et nous avons euh effectivement euh
pris position là-dessus sur le fait que
le rassemblement national n'a clairement
pas coupé avec ses origines antisémite
et que à ce titre euh il est illégitime
à participer à une marche contre
l'antisémitisme aujourd'hui euh il
essaie de d'utiliser l'antisémitisme
pour se racheter une une virginité et
surtout parce que ça permet de taper sur
les musulmans et donc ça ça n'est pas
possible al c'est pas ce que dit Jordan
bardellainin lui il dit que son parti
est aujourd'hui irréprochable sur cette
question de l'antisémitisme FA 15 ans
qu'il alerte sur le il dit aussi que
Jean-Marie Le Pen n'est pas antisémite
donc on va pas vraiment le prendre
prendre au mot mais pour vous vous irez
quand même à cette marche c'est pas un
frein pour pour aller marcher on va pas
on va pas pouvoir marcher au côté de
l'extrême droite mais mais
l'antisémitisme doit être un appel
universel vis-à-vis de tous les citoyens
et donc c'est important que nous
répondions présent la France insoumise
elle réserve sa réponse manuel monpard
dit qu'il devait en discuter vous
comprenez pardon la France insoumise qui
réserve sa réponse on va parler du tweet
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon mais le
coordinateur de la France insoumise
manuel bonpard dit pour le moment qu'il
réserve sa réponse écoutez on va on va
voir ce qu'ils font je pense que
aujourd'hui il y a des clairement des
problèmes au niveau en tout cas de de la
direction de la France insoumise par
rapport à à cette question parce queils
essaient toujours de trouver des des
positions qu'ils estiment eux être des
positions d'équilibre qui en réalité
sont des positions intenable intenable
pourquoi euh parce que on peut pas dans
le tweet de Jean-Luc mange on peut pas
parler de prétexte d'antisémitisme on va
voir un ce t de de Jean-Luc Mélanchon
euh qui qualifie cette marche en disant
les amis du soutien inconditionnel au
massacre on leur rendez-vous comment
vous comment vous réagissez à ça c'est
une fite en avant enfin je je crois que
il s'est engagé dans une mauvaise voie
et il essaie de de de prouver que c'est
la bonne en en en continuant dans cette
dans cette fuite en avant ça n'a ça n'a
pas de sens j'espère pour lui que son
empressement à l'outrance a dépasser sa
pensée et en parlant vous l'avez dit de
prétexte prétexte sous prétexte
antisémitisme de lutte contre
l'antisémitisme ouais oui oui c'est
grave mais est-ce que là il a franchi
une nouvelle ligne
rouge jeis je crois que ça fait un
moment qu'il est au-delà de la LI rouge
sur ces sur ces questions je moi je je
je pense que c'est je crois pas que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon soit lui-même
antisémite mais je crois qu' il est dans
un emballement où il s'est plus
s'arrêter il s'est plus s'arrêter parce
qu'il doit à tout prix justifier le
mauvais chemin qu'il a pris au départ on
va parler de l'immigration dans dans
quelques instants un dernier mot sur
l'actualité puisque Emmanuel Macron a
convié les chefs de parti à une nouvelle
rencontre à Saint-Denis le 17 novembre
prochain Olivier fort nous annoncé sur
ce plateau qu'il n'irait pas est-ce que
la politique de la chaise vide ça va
mener bien loin alors on n' pas mené la
politique de la chaise vide puisque au
départ nous avions participé à ces
rencontres de Saint-Denis Olivier fort
était on a il a participé et nous avons
fait des propositions par rapport à ça
mais ce qu'on a constaté c'est
qu'ensuite il s'est rien passé que
aucune des propositions qui ont été
faites par la gauche n'ont été pris au
sérieux et que en réalité ça sert
uniquement d'alibi à Emmanuel Macron
pour prétendre qu'il a consulté et il
continue lui à faire ce qu'il avait
décidé de faire avant de voir qui que ce
soit donc voilà donc c'est devenu une
mascarade ça n'a plus aucun sens puis là
on voit bien que ce qu'il veut faire
c'est c'est d'abord tendre la main à la
droite et à l'extrême droite puisque ce
qu' commence par faire c'est mettre la
question de l'immigration dans un
référendum sur la table et d'ailleurs
c'est Jordan Bardella qui a le premier
accepté cette invitation et donc ça veut
tout dire on va parler de la loi
immigration puisque vous poursuivez en
séance l'examen de ce texte hier soir la
majorité sénatoriale a trouvé un accord
sur le fameux article 3 qui régularise
les travailleurs sans papier dans les
métiers entention on fait le point sur
tout ça avec notre journaliste
parlementaire Steve
[Musique]
jouran bonjour Steve bonjouran bonjour
madame la sénatrice et Steve ça y est
c'est le jour J pour l'article qu'on
attend tous l'article 3 oui l'article
qui rend fou un peu tout le monde dans
la majorité sénatoriale est-ce que j'ai
besoin de vous rappeler ce qui est
l'article 3 quand même un rappel VO la
délivrance de plein droit d'une carte de
séjour temporaire à un étranger qui
travaille pendant au moins 8 mois dans
un secteur en tension le blocage sur
cette article dur dur depuis plusieurs
mois il a fallu du temps pour apaiser
les tensions au sein de de la majorité
sénatoriale l'article 3 ou ce qu'il en
reste devrait être discuté aujourd'hui
dans la soirée Orian parce que les
choses ont avancé hier soir oui fumée
blanche aperçu hier dans la soirée on va
voir ce communiqué publié par Bruno
rotaillo le chef du groupe LR après
discussion les LR se sont entendus avec
les centristes d'herv Marseille la
majorité sénatoriale s'accorde pour
supprimer les articles 3 et 4 du projet
de loi sur l'immigration et pour durcir
les conditions d'application de la
circulaire Val c'est l'article 3 donc on
vient d'en parler l'article 4 porte lui
sur la procédure d'asile Orian c'est un
compromis entre la ligne du gouvernement
et les propositions des républicains
plus ferme sur cette question de
régularisation des il faut expliquer ce
qui est la la circulaire valsexte 2012
qui permet aux étrangers en situation
irrégulière qui sont en France depuis au
moins 5 ans et qui travaillent de
demander leur régularisation il faut
avoir bossé au moins 8 mois sur les deux
dernières années pour obtenir un titre
l'accord LR centrist prévoit donc du
durcir les conditions de régularisation
de ces s papiers à noter que l'accord
demande de laisser les mains libres au
préfet ça sera à eux de dire si oui ou
non l'étranger en question remplit les
critères de régularisation et parmi ces
critères la majorité sénatoriale veut
inclure notamment l'intégration ou non
de l'individu dans la société et son
adhésion ou non aux valeurs de la
République madame la sénatrice vous
saluer ce compromis entre les centristes
et les alr bien sûr que non bien sûr que
non l'article 3 était déjà pour nous euh
le minimum de ce qu'on pouvait faire en
matière de régularisation de ceux qui
travaill dans ce pays et et donc le fait
que là il soit supprimé pour être
remplacé par des mesures qui sont encore
plus restrictifs que ce qui existe déjà
dans le droit français ça n'est pas pour
nous acceptable et je note par ailleurs
c'est pas je pense que ça n'est pas une
coïncidence que cet accord est par
parvenu au moment même où le
gouvernement a laissé la droite
supprimer l'aide médicale d'État en
séance hier soir dans les débats voilà
donc c'est concomitant monsieur Darmanin
n'était plus sur les
bans de de l'hémicycle lorsque nous
était en train de débattre de la de du
maintien ou pas de l'aide médicale
d'État il était en train de négocier
pour vous le gouvernement écoutez c'est
c'était dans le même c'est le même
moment donc on peut se poser la question
quand même et et le gouvernement qui
pourtant réaffirmé son attachement et je
dois dire d'ailleurs avec un plédoyer
excellent qu'on aurait pu faire
nous-même qu'on a fait nous-même euh de
de de la ministre firm lebodo pour
ensuite donner un avis de sagesse
c'est-à-dire de laisser la droite
sénatoriale faire euh et ça euh ça n'est
pas acceptable ça n'est pas de ça n'est
pas comme ça qu'on défend laame mais je
suppose qu'onou on va
revenir sur l'article 3 euh bien sûr
nous nous opposerons à la suppression de
l'article 3 qure mais nous sommes
minoritaires euh donc qui maintenant il
reviendra quand même rien parce que ça
va permettre quand même des
régularisation de de non parce qu' alors
justement puisquil il annonce que ça va
restreindre encore l'application de la
de la circulaire V puis qu'
effffectivement la circulaire V n'est
pas réduite n'est pas contrainte au
métiers entention alors que là on va
contraindre aux métiers enenstion qui
par ailleurs sont très mal définis vous
savez que dans les métiers entention
aujourd'hui par exemple c'est pas très
clair que l'hôtellerie en fait partie
alors que on c'est bien que ça fait
partie des des métiers ention donc il y
a il y a vraiment un énorme sujet et la
circulaire vase aujourd'hui c'est à peu
près 7000 euh régularisations par an ce
qui est vraiment très très peu en
réalité cette circulire donc il y a une
espèce de voilà il y a une espèce de
fantasme de la droite sur cette question
des régularisations alors que ce sont
des hommes et des femmes qui font
tourner notre notre pays et on l'a vu
notamment dans la crise covid euh il y a
pas très longtemps et on conserve la
circulaire Vals il faut la conserver
cette circulaire écoutez c'est la la
circulaire Vals euh c'est le c'est le
minimum mais nous ce qu'on nous ce qu'on
demandait c'est que on inscrive dans la
loi et nous on voulait aller encore plus
loin que l'article 3 estce que ce que
d'ailleurs maintenant on va passer le
relais on sera obligé contraint de
passer le relais aux députés là-dessus
en espérant que ils reviendront sur
cette sur cette suppression au début du
mois de de décembre nous à gauche nous
les socialistes ce qu'on défend c'est
d'aller encore plus loin même ce qu'il y
avait dans l'article 3 c'estàdire de ne
pas restreindre uniquement au métier en
tension et de de dire que à partir du
moment où on travaille depuis au moins 6
mois que on puisse être régularisé sur
qui comptez-vous à l'Assemblée pour pour
acter cette suppression alors on a vu
qu'il y a une partie des députés il y a
bien sûr la gauche toute la gauche et il
y a une partie des députés Renaissance
voilà qui sera pas majoritaire mais il y
a une partie des députés Renaissance qui
qui soutiennent aussi cet article 3 dans
sa dans sa version initiale qui comme
vous comptez sur l'aile gauche de la
majorité pour ne pas voter le texte et
en tout cas pour pour vous aider à
supprimer cette oui oui absolument mais
bon après on verra puisque le
gouvernement peut utiliser le 493 à
l'Assemblée donc on verra ce qui se
passera ce qu'il va faire selon vous
parce que Gérard lin il dit il y aura
bien un article de régularisation pour
les travailleurs en tension et c'est
c'est une très bonne chose oui c'est une
c'est une pierrouette c'està direire
qu'il y a un article qui va qui va qui
va appeler à une circulaire je l'ai pas
encore vu mais enfin de ce que j'en
comprends puisqu'il est censé être basé
sur un amendement qui avait été déposé
par RV Marseille par l'Union
centriste qui qui serait donc une
régularisation sur avec la le le pouvoir
qui qui reconnaît le pouvoir
discrétionnaire des préfets pour des
régularisation à titre
exceptionnel donc on voit bien que là
c'est uniquement
pour mettre dans la loi en fait que la
circulaire vase est caduque et qu'on va
faire encore pire voilà en'est qu'est-ce
que vous ferez ce soir en séance est-ce
que quand même vous défendrez un retour
en arrière ou est-ce que la bataille
politique est perdu B de toute façon il
faut qu'on affirme nos position et qu'on
et qu'on porte une vision différente de
de la de des immigrés dans ce pays et
d'ailleurs en fait les Français sont
majoritairement pour en fait la
régularisation parce qu'il voit bien
bien que voilà il y a des gens qui
travaillent qui pour X raisons sont
aujourd'hui irréguliers parfois ils sont
arrivés de manière régulière dans le
territoire ils sont du irrégulier depuis
parce que par ailleurs nos procédures
pour pour obtenir descart pluannuel sont
très
compliqué et et donc il faut porter
quand même cette vision de l'intégration
par le travail dans dans la République
c'est important donc on va mener la
bataille même si on sait bien qu'on sera
pas majoritaire le le gouvernement
projetait environ 7000 nouvelles
régularisations par avec son projet de
loi selon vous combien de régularisation
dans ces métiers tention serait
aujourd'hui nécessaire alors c'est pas à
moi de le dire parce que je je moi j'ai
on n pas suffisamment chess de faire
chifr le gouvernement parle de 7000 7000
c'est ce qui existe aujourd'hui donc en
fait et là ce qui va se passer avec avec
cette nouvelle
version de de la loi ça sera
probablement encore moins puisque cette
m c'est grâce à la circulaire Vals et
qui qui va être de ce que je comprends
encore plus eu donc avec une disposition
qui sera encore plus contraignante donc
euh selon il fallut audessus de 7000 et
on a bien sûr mais mais nous on pense
par ailleurs comme je l'ai dit de qu'il
faut aller au-delà des métiers des
métiers dit en tension puisque en
réalité il y a une une très grosse
hypocrisie qui est que il y a certains
métiers qui sont pas considérés en
tension parce que les employeurs ne les
déclarent pas comme des métiers où ils
ont ils ont des offres non remplies
puisque justement ils embauchent
irrégulièrement euh illégalement des des
des personnes qui qui sont ici de
manière irrégulière donc et donc il y a
a une forte hypocrisie sur fait qu'il y
a des endroits où on sait qu'il y a
plein de travailleurs immigrés
illégaux qui travaillent et et et qui
font tourner notre économie et qui
cotisent par ailleurs souvent et
donc vous avez pas de projection vous
avez pas de chiffres précis sur sur sur
ce nombre de régularisations qui serait
souhaitable aujourd'ui mais nous on n
pas on n'est pas pour des politiques de
quota et donc on veut pas euh annoncer
des chiffres on veut simplement que il y
ait une politique de justice et queil y
ait des droits qui sont des droits
fondamentaux qui soient des droits
opposable pour tous tous ceux qui
remplissent certains critères et donc
pas de dire qu'on va remplir certains
cotas c'est c'est c'est une question
éthique et pas seulement économique
comme on peut l'entendre du côté du
gouvernement où il y a cet aspect voilà
y a des besoins dans certains métiers
entention des pineries de mainœvre bien
sûr mais c'est les deux c'est y a une
question il y a une question éthique il
a une question d'une certaine vision de
la France de de de la République mais il
aussi une question effectivement
d'efficacité d'efficacité économique et
de et de de besoins à remplir dans notre
pays bien sûr on revient sur l'ame
l'aide médicale d'État qui a été
transformé hier en en en Amu en aide
médicale d'urgence avec donc un panier
de soins restreint vous le disiez le
gouvernement est divisé Agnès fmain
lebaudau était sur votre ligne elle a
défendu votre position mais le
gouvernement au final a donné un avis de
sagesse c'est-à-dire qu'il s'est pas
prononcé sur ce texte qu'est-ce que vous
attendez désormais du gouvernement sur
cette question oui je regrette qu'il se
cache derrière leur petit Doig avec
cette avec ce cette mission qui a été
commandée à à claudv à claudvin et
Patrick Stéphan voilà euh par oui parce
que d'autant plus que la ministre
elle-même a dit hier soir que que ce
rapport ne ne vise pas à à à
éventuellement remettre en cause laame
mais à regarder si elle comment elle
peut être améliorée donc à partir de ce
moment-là je vois pas pourquoi ils
utilisent la le prétexte de ce rapport
pour pour pour refuser de de de soutenir
nos amendements les amendements de la
gauche et aussi ailleurs du groupe RDPI
qui qui soutient a priori qui est proche
du gouvernement qui qui demand RP c'est
le groupe des sénateurs renaissan ici
voilà et donc et donc qui qui qui qui
soutenait le fait de de de de supprimer
la suppression de laame de supprimer
l'article qui a été introduit par par la
droite et qui transformait l'ame en AM
donc ça pour le coup vous espérez que le
gouvernement aille dans votre sens et
bien il faut qu' re s faut rattrappe à
l'Assemblée nationale mais il y a aucune
excuse de de pas l'avoir fait déjà hier
soir au Sénat le Sénat qui est également
hier soir rétabli le délit de séjours
irrégulier il avait été supprimé par
François Holland en 2012 qu'en
pensez-vous al c'est une succession de
recul depuis depuis lundi d'abord il y a
eu beaucoup de recul sur le regroupement
familial avec cette idée que quand on
est étranger on n' pas droit à une vie
familiale ou qu'on si on que qu'on est
forcément suspect de vouloir frauder de
VO c'est insupportable mais voilà donc
il y a eu des restrictions très fortes
sur le recoupement familial qui ont été
voté et maintenant effectivement le fait
de
de nouveau pénaliser le le séjour
irrégulier et qui et qui donc en plus va
dans un sens qui ne va pas faciliter
l'application de cette de même ce de ce
qu'il en reste d'une circulaire de
régularisation des travailleurs on
suivra évidemment l'examen de ce texte
aujourd'hui avec le fameux article 3 qui
sera donc examiné en séance St à tout à
l'heure tout à l'heure on parlera de la
marche contre l'antisémitisme prévu
dimanche ce sera à suivre dans le club
on va aller voir l'actualité
territoriale maintenant Corina gar on
trouve Jacques Paquier directeur de la
rédaction du journal du Grand Paris
bonjour Jacques merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous Jacques vouliz revenir avec la
sénatrice sur le plan anti-émeute
dévoilé il y a quelques jours par
ellisabeth borne absolument oui comme
vous le savez madame la sénatrice
l'objectif de du gouvernement en
l'occurrence c'est de d'éviter si
tantais que ce soit possible que des des
émeutes teles que celles qui son sont
déroulé notamment dans votre département
de scè Saint-Denis pas seulement bien
sûr mais aussi en scè Saint-Denis l'été
dernier se reproduisent pour se faire
100 millions d'euros qui sont mis sur la
table pour reconstruire cela alors même
que l'association des merdî de France
présidé par Stéphane baudet évalue à 56
millions d'euros les les dégâts
provoqués pour la seule île de France
lors des émeutes donc 100 millions
d'euros sur la table et puis une série
de mesures la création d'une force
d'action républicaine une augmentation
des amendes à 750 € si on respecte pas
le le couvre-feu un encadrement
potentiel des des délinquants par les
militaires je voulais savoir madame la
sénatrice ce que vous en penseiez est-ce
que pour vous c'est de nature tout
simplement à ce que et bien les émeutes
ne se reproduisent pas ou est-ce que il
vous semble que c'est pas forcément
suffisant ou ou bien adapté alors le le
la reconstruction c'est c'est je pense
c'est normal c'est le minimum mais mais
euh je crois que il y a il y a une forme
de d'aveuglement volontaire du du
gouvernement sur cette question là parce
que même si euh il y a a un affichage de
de volonté de prendre soi-disant le
sujet à 360°gr avec des mesures plutôt
répressives mais avec aussi des mesures
qui sont affichées comme des mesures
plus sociales ou plus portées sur
l'éducation je crains que ça soit encore
enfin des comité théodu là je sais pas
très bien comment ça va fonctionner
cette nouvelle force euh on peut espérer
que ça fonctionne mais enfin ça n'est
pas très convainquant pour l'instant ça
paraît être des des des vux pieux sur le
papier qui on va avoir une une une
efficacité opérationnel assez limité et
puis surtout il y a une forme de
stigmatisation euh systématique des
parents euh et et de toute une
population de de de certains quartiers
comme étant nécessairement irresponsable
ou incapable de de s'intégrer sans
reconnaître la complexité euh des sujets
qui sont pas seulement des questions
d'éducation mais des questions aussi
évidemment le les émeutes sont sont
toujours inexcusables mais mais la la la
colère qu' qu'elles ont exprimé euh ont
euh ont des sources qui sont réelles par
rapport aux conditions de logement par
rapport aux conditions d'accès à du
travail et puis par rapport aussi à la
relation entre la police et la et la et
la population et ça c'est c'est là où je
dis qu'il y a une forme d'avonglement
volontaire du gouvernement c'est que ce
sujet-là qui est quand même à la source
des émeutes ça ça n'est pas du tout
considéré par le gouvernement il y a
aucune aucune proposition
là-dessus alors à ce ça oui justement il
m'a semblé mais sans forcément que ce
soit très clair qu'il y a une volonté de
redistribuer ou de permettre une
redistribution des missions entre police
nationale d'une part police municipale
d'autre part vous avez une opinion vous
sur les le rôle respectif de ces deux
deux branches si j'ose dire de la police
alors c'est une réflexion importante
qu'on peut pas improviser parce
qu'effectivement il doit y avoir un
continuum de de de sécurité entre entre
la la la la police nationale et la
police municipale avec des prérogatives
qui soient clairement définies pour les
uns et pour les autres le problème c'est
que on peut pas non plus avoir un
gouvernement qui maintenant va se
décharger sur des polices municipales
alors que les communautés les les
collectivités sont déjà euh ont déjà des
problèmes pour boucler leur leur budget
et et et que par ailleurs voilà il a il
y a aussi des questions de ce que la la
police municipale peut faire vraiment en
terme de droit de et en terme
règlementairire on peut pas improviser
ces choseslà et puis et puis c'est
d'abord le rôle de enfin la question se
pose d'abord sur la la police nationale
c'est la police nationale qui doit
réparer sa sa relation avec avec la
population général et avec toute une
partie des jeunes des quartiers en
particulier c'est depuis évidemment la
suppression de la police de proximité
qu'on voit ces problèmes et qu'on ne
voit pas en zone gendarmerie qui
pourtant opère aussi dans des dans des
zones où il y a des quartiers politiques
de la ville donc on voit bien là qu'il y
a un problème spécifique avec la police
nationale et qui il y a besoin de moyens
il y a besoin de formation une autre
question Jacques sur un autre sujet vous
allez nous parler de la de la mission
qu'a confié Emmanuel Macron à Eric vert
sur la décentralisation la
simplification territoriale absolument
mission chè madame de donc demander à à
Eric ver de clarification de l'action
publique locale et d'identification de
nouvelles pistes de décentralisation
vous êtes une sénatrice de de
d'île-france de sa saint-lenis donc je
peux résiste pas la à au plaisir de vous
poser la question de savoir quelle
vision vous portez sur l'organisation
territoriale en Île-de-France ou
où comme vous le savez le millefeuille
est assez riche puisqu'il compte 5
strates commune groupement de commune
métropole département région est-ce
qu'il vous semble chère Madame que le
problème est dans un excès de strat
est-ce qu' pour le dire plus simplement
est-ce qu'il faut en supprimer une et si
oui laquelle alors je veux pas rentrer
dans le détail de ces débats aujourd'
alors en tant que socialiste je suis
évidemment pour que on examine la
question de la décentralisation pour
qu'elle soit plus complète et plus eff
mais mais
justement supprimer des des strites il
faut pas que ça soit au détriment de la
capacité à agir en proximité euh et donc
alors on peut peut-être se poser je
pense que s'il y a une question à se
poser elle se pose plus sur la question
de la métropole du Grand Paris que sur
la question des département parce qu'on
a bien vu notamment que
sur que sur les les quand quand on est
on a des périodes de crise quand on a
notamment eu la période covid que ce
sont d'abord les mairies et les
départements qui sont en première ligne
et qui sont d'abord au service de nos
concitoyens et donc ces stratesl sont
particulièrement importantes et au-delà
de
l'île-defance je je crois que on voit
bien maintenant en plus avec les grandes
régions que ces strates de proximité là
sont particulièrement importantes à
préserver merci jaces Paquier merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous on
regarde la Une du journal du Grand Paris
renforcer la boîte à outils et la
mobilisation de tous les acteurs c'est à
la Une de votre journal cette semaine
merci beaucoup merci Jacques d'avoir été
avec nous merci Corina rassiguin d'avoir
été notre invité pour cette première
demi-heure